Okay, so we are back at the screen.
Welcome to video number 22. We're going to
move on to the
next stage of the Professional Trading
Masterclass video series. We're going to
move on to a big
part of our process, very important trade
idea generation. And the first part of
which is the
quantitative processing phase. But first,
we need to cover some ground in order to
build
into the first stage of the trade idea
generation process to better understand
how everything
fits together here. So, so far in the PTM
video series, we have looked at obtaining
a macro view
and learned absolute necessary information
to understand how long short portfolio
management
actually works when covering in the PTM
video series, the foundations of long
short portfolio
management. We've covered a lot of ground
and put in some hard yards. And of course,
there's still a lot of hard
yards left to cover. Now, the stuff that
we've learned so far in the PTM video
series, and sections
that we're going to cover in the remainder
of the PTM video series, the best way to
think of the information
information is to split it out in your
mind into two distinct parts. So, firstly,
information that is fixed and learned
once. That can never change. And process,
secondly, that you continuously
engage in. For example, if you started the
PTM video series as a complete novice and
didn't even understand what a yield curve
is,
what a yield curve is. Well, guess what?
Now you do. That information is not going
to change ever. You've learnt it once
and it's done and it's done. However, on a
weekly basis, knowing where interest rates
are across the yield curve and
understanding what is going on and what it
means for GDP expectations, equities and
your portfolio bias at any one
specific moment in time. That requires
weekly processing. Another example with
the ISM
the ISM Manufacturing Report on Business
and the Non-Manufacturing Report on
Business, ISM Services.
Knowing what it is, how it's designed and
what the numbers mean is only something
you have to learn once. On a continuous
basis, interpreting the data on a monthly
basis, knowing how it affects your
macroeconomic view.
On the future of GDP growth, S&P 500
direction and your portfolio bias. Looking
within the surveys for sectoral
growth, you've got multiple trends. You've
got multiple trends and qualitative
commentary and clues in order to help with
trade idea generation. That is a regular
process of engagement. So guys, guess
what? You have to show up and you have to
do your
your processes regularly. Another example.
In the section in the PTM video series
that
Chris covered in Foundations of Portfolio
Management. What did we learn? We learned
about Portfolio Modeling, Portfolio
Volatility, Portfolio Correlation and
Beta. That's a one-time thing. Once you've
learned how it works, you learn it once
and the
you know. On a continuous basis, modelling
your portfolio, knowing the volatility and
correlation of your portfolio and
understanding your portfolio bias and your
opportunity and risk of the portfolio via
beta is a regular process that you have to
engage in. Again, this is an ongoing
process. We will engage in more of this
throughout the video series.
Now, in the current section that we're
going to go through now of the PTM video
series, we're going to go through
more processes, more processes, but in the
trade idea generation phase. Additionally,
you are going to learn in this
phase, more stuff that you only have to
learn once. And you're going to learn more
stuff that you're going to have to
apply continuously. Now, as you've heard
us say before at ITPM, retail traders do
everything the wrong way around
and upside down. And this definitely
applies here in the formation of trade
ideas that may or may not end up in your
portfolio.
Now, just as a reminder to set the scene
as we're moving into the trade idea
generation phase, remember, we are
operating in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon.
And you have to remember what constitutes
an actual trade idea within that time
horizon.
We are not investors and we are not day
traders. We are trading 20 to 60 day
volatility.
And if you recall, we have a pro trader
systematic process within the 20 to 60 day
time horizon.
That drives and generates our trade ideas
that end up going into a live portfolio.
And our trade ideas are driven primarily
by fundamentals.
We also have to time our trades as best as
we can.
And we also require catalysts within the
20 to 60 day time horizon for our stocks
to move within that time period.
And our trade structures consider the
catalysts that are occurring or are
available in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon.
However, the vast majority of what we do
is driven by fundamentals.
So fundamentals are the start of
everything for a trade idea.
And those fundamentals are split into two
areas, the quantitative processing phase
and the qualitative processing phase.
Fundamentals make up 80 to 90 percent of
the factors that we consider as drivers to
whether a stock becomes
a long or short trade idea or a long or
short trade idea.
And then timing.
Once we have decided that something, a
stock is a fundamental long or short,
timing is 10 to 20 percent of the factors
that we consider for a stock to actually
become a long trade idea or a short trade
idea.
So within the 20 to 60 day time horizon.
And then the trade structure that we
choose is simply a representation of the
catalysts that are available to us that
we've identified within the 20 to 60 day
time horizon that are going to make the
stock move.
So our first step, fundamentals, the
quantitative and qualitative processes of
fundamentals.
Fundamentals.
This is a theoretical step.
to work out whether that identification
process of the fundamental long and the
fundamental short,
we are using the timing step to find out
if it is advantageous or not to take the
position within the 20 to 60 day time
horizon.
And when we are seeking to implement, we
require catalysts and an identification of
catalysts to enable the stock to move
within the time period.
And our trade structure is a
representation of this.
So, in short, our trade idea generation
process is an identification process.
Fundamentals first, we are identifying
interesting, potential longs and shorts
based on fundamentals, 80 to 90% of our
work.
We are then appraising and identifying
whether the timing looks advantageous or
not.
We are also identifying catalysts that can
occur within the 20 to 60 day time horizon
and our trade structure becomes a
representation of that.
That is the overall trade idea generation
process.
And it's important to think of the pro
trader systematic process and the steps
that we go through to generate a trade
idea
versus the steps that a retail trader goes
through to generate a trade idea.
So, professional traders are putting a
very large weighting on fundamentals and
the drivers of fundamentals to generate a
trade idea.
What are retail traders doing?
Well, they're doing everything upside
down.
Generally speaking, they're putting the
vast majority of their weighting on
timing.
Then, professional traders, we have
fundamentals and catalysts that are going
to move a stock within a 20 to 60 day time
horizon.
They're putting way too much emphasis on
one-dimensional risk management and then
the risk management and timing is
dictating their outcome.
So, there's no diversification in their
portfolios.
So, they only have a few positions that
are driven by mostly technicals and not
fundamentals.
So, what ends up happening?
The vast majority lose money.
So, what ends up in a retail trader's
portfolio is essentially too few badly
thought out, badly timed ideas.
What ends up in a professional trader's
portfolio is a good amount of well thought
out, highly researched, fundamentally
driven,
well-timed trade ideas that have been
structured well.
And that is a huge difference in the gulf
between retail traders and professional
traders.
And these are not subtle little
differences, guys, between retail traders
and professional traders.
This is a massive difference.
It's a massive amount of understanding at
work to just get on top of it and, on a
continuous basis, implement the overall
pro trader systematic process.
And this is, of course, what you're here
to learn.
You're here to learn this, to close the
gap between retail traders and
professional traders.
So, close the gap between what you've been
doing previously and what professional
traders do.
And what you've learned so far, you know,
we've learned macroeconomic indicators
that give us our portfolio bias.
We've learned the basics, the foundations
of portfolio management, of long, short
portfolio management.
And now we're moving into the next phase
of our education, the trade idea
generation process.
And the majority of what professional
trainers do is rooted in fundamentals.
It is an identification process.
So, we have our macro, which is
quantitative.
And that's part of the quantitative
process that dictates our bias, whether we
lean to be long, short or neutral in our
portfolio.
So, that is our top-down analysis.
Additionally, as part of the quantitative
process within fundamentals is our micro
views.
This is our bottom-up analysis.
And this is where we start identifying
potential longs and shorts for our
portfolio.
And we go through a trade idea generation
process, starting with the bottom-up
analysis on stocks as part of the
quantitative process.
We are seeking microeconomic views on
stocks as to whether something is a
fundamental long or a fundamental short.
And it is an identification process.
We identify the potential longs and we
identify the potential shorts.
We ask ourselves the question at the
quantitative stage of trade idea
generation.
Is this stock on paper a quantitative
potential long?
potential short?
It is an identification process.
And the answers will either be yes, no, or
don't know.
And then we move on to the qualitative
process, which comes much later in the
video series after we've been through the
whole quantitative processes of the trade
idea generation steps.
And the qualitative process, we are
learning more about the stock information.
We are identifying key performance
indicators and we are also identifying
catalysts.
But for now, we are going to go through
the quantitative processes step by step.
But first, before we get into the meat of
those processes, I think it's very
important for you to understand.
At this stage, why professional traders
put so much emphasis on trade ideas and
fundamentally driven trade ideas and the
quality of their trade ideas versus risk
management.
It's very straightforward, guys, when you
think about it.
If you just ask yourself a very, very
simple question.
Who would you rather be for the rest of
your life?
Trader 1 or Trader 2?
So let's say we have two choices.
Trader 1, Trader 2.
Trader 1 is bad at ideas, but excellent at
risk management.
And Trader 2 is excellent at ideas, but
bad at risk management.
There's only two things that go into the
outcome of whether we make a profit or
loss.
It's either trade ideas or risk management
or a combination of both.
So if you were given the choice, if you
had to be good or bad at one or the other,
which one would you choose?
Trader 1, would you choose to be that
trader for the rest of your life?
Bad at ideas, excellent at risk
management.
Or Trader 2, excellent at ideas and bad at
risk management.
Which one would you choose?
Well, given the information that we've
shown you so far, I'd hope you'd lean
towards Trader 2.
But retail traders are doing everything
upside down.
Retail traders, as mentioned previously,
have too little, badly thought out ideas,
but they believe they're excellent at risk
management.
So the way retail traders are taught and
how they evolve or how they even teach
themselves, they're learning superficial
risk management and thinking that for some
reason, no matter how bad the ideas are
that they put into their trading account,
as long as they manage their risk well,
they only have upside, that's wrong,
because if your ideas are bad over a long
period of time, it doesn't matter how good
your risk management is, you're just going
to go to zero.
However, very few people understand that
the opposite case in the real world
doesn't actually hold true.
So, if somebody has excellent ideas, an
abundance of excellent ideas, but they're
bad at risk management, does that mean
they go to zero?
In reality, no.
Because what matters is the quality of
your ideas.
Bad ideas and good risk management is not
the same outcome as good ideas and bad
risk management.
So, if we replace those boxes and we
replace trade ideas with the quality of
ideas and we replace risk management with
the variability of your risk,
and we call that the black box
variability, it's those two things that
really matter in the real world as to
whether you make money over time.
So, think about it.
For the rest of your life, who would you
rather be?
And we're talking about a series of trades
here over an extremely long period of
time.
We're not talking about opening a trading
account and having one or two trades that
go well over a period of one or two
months.
We're talking about a career.
We're talking about a lifetime.
We're talking about thousands of trades
over and over and over again.
So, let's run through some outcomes of
what that actually looks like over an
extended career of thousands of trades.
If you put lots of emphasis on your ideas
and very little emphasis and understanding
of your risk management.
So, you put all of your effort into the
quality of your ideas and you put very
little effort into risk management.
What's going to happen over time with an
endless amount of trades?
Well, this person is the reckless genius.
We would score them very, very high on the
quality of their ideas.
So, we give them an 8 out of 10.
But we give them a very low score for
their black box variability.
We give them a 2 out of 10 for their risk
management, the variability of their risk
within what we call the black box.
Open quotes, close quotes.
The black box is basically where your risk
occurs.
Your risk management occurs.
How you deal with a position for the rest
of your career.
So, this person, the quality of their
ideas is very high.
But their risk management is bad.
What do we call that guy?
Well, we call that guy the reckless
genius.
That person on a linear score would score
10 out of 20 because they're getting 8 for
the quality of their ideas, but 2 for
their risk management, their black box
variability.
But in reality, what's going to happen to
this person?
Well, they're getting a lot of their ideas
right.
And they just need a few ideas to get huge
upside over a very long period of time,
over a large amount of trades.
In the real world, they would actually be
scored higher.
So, their P&L would come out not on a
linear move, not on a linear score, but on
a projected score that's higher.
Now, think of the opposite of that.
So, somebody who has got terrible ideas,
but really good risk management for the
rest of their life.
What's actually happening to this person?
Well, this person we call the firefighter.
This person is putting terrible ideas into
a black box that has little variability.
But for the rest of their career, this is
the case.
They're putting hundreds, thousands of
low-quality, terrible, crappy ideas into a
portfolio that manages risk well.
Well, what are they doing for the rest of
their life?
All they're doing for the rest of their
life is putting out fires.
And on a linear score, they score 10 out
of 20.
That's the same score as the reckless
genius.
But it's obviously not the same outcome in
the real world.
In the real world, their P&L will go to
zero.
On a projection, we would score this
person very, very low on the outcome of
their portfolio.
Perhaps a 6 out of 20.
So if given the choice between being the
firefighter for the rest of your life or
the reckless genius for the rest of your
life,
I think it's fairly obvious we would much
rather be the reckless genius.
Yes, we will get trades wrong and they
will cost us quite a lot of money.
But the reckless genius has a large amount
of high-quality trade ideas that are
coming through their process for the rest
of their life.
They're just managing the risk badly on
some of them.
So they're getting a large amount right.
The quality of the ideas is high.
The firefighter has got a very low quality
of ideas.
So they have a large amount of terrible
ideas.
And they're putting out fires for the rest
of their lives.
Very few of them go right.
And the vast majority are going wrong.
They're just managing the risk well on all
of the positions that are going wrong.
But there's so many of them that they're
just going to go to zero over an infinite
amount of trades,
over an infinite amount of time.
We would much rather be the reckless
genius.
There's far much more upside over
thousands of trades in this person's
portfolio,
in this person's trading process, than the
firefighter.
And what's an unfortunate reality in the
real world is that retail traders,
when they learn and when they evolve, or
as the case may be, not evolve,
what they're focusing on the most and what
they're taught to focus on the most
is all the stuff that doesn't matter.
So all the stuff like risk management.
So focusing on some superficial,
one-dimensional risk management metrics
and not focusing on the quality of their
ideas.
And if you look at case number three here,
the guy that's got one out of 10 for
quality of ideas
and the black box variability of three out
of 10,
so a linear score of four.
Unfortunately, in the real world,
this is what the picture of the retail
trader actually is.
People think that risk management is the
most important thing.
And they think they're actually good at
risk management because they know some
superficial metrics.
But the reality is, is that they're not.
So the quality of their ideas is very low.
And their risk management is extremely
basic.
And what ends up happening is they just go
towards zero
and tend to end up at zero over a large
amount of trades over a long enough period
of time.
Now, where do we want to be?
Where do we want to be as professional
traders, i.e. at a professional trading
standard?
Well, we'd much rather be the reckless
genius than the firefighter if given the
choice.
And, of course, we definitely don't want
to be the useless pleb.
But we do have a choice in the direction
that we take our careers
and how we structure our processes to get
consistency in returns
and favorable portfolio outcomes, as in
consistent profitability.
We do have a choice where we put our
efforts in.
So where would we want to be?
We want to be highly competent at the
quality of our ideas.
And we want to be highly competent at risk
management or black box variability.
We don't have to be absolute geniuses and
get 10 out of 10 all the time
on our quality of our ideas.
We don't have to have that.
We can just be highly competent.
So a 7 out of 10 for our quality of ideas
will do.
That will give us enough consistency to
come up with a large amount
of high-quality trade ideas over time.
For risk management, again, we don't have
to be the greatest risk managers on the
planet.
We would rather be competent or highly
competent at risk management.
And a 7 out of 10 will do.
We don't want to be the firefighter.
Absolutely not.
Quality of ideas really matters.
But we don't want to give up too much
somewhere else in areas like risk
management
for the sake of just having a 10 out of 10
for the quality of our ideas.
To get consistency in returns, we need
consistency in approach.
And quality of ideas really matters.
And risk management, of course, matters
too.
So we want to be highly competent at both.
This will give us consistent profitability
and a high score over time.
But what's interesting about risk
management processes is that once you've
learned them, once you've learned them
once,
you don't have to learn them again.
It just comes down to experience.
And this is why we call the box for risk
management, black box variability.
Why?
Because over time, once you've learned it,
it's fixed.
The variability becomes fixed.
What is variable in the process is the
quality of your ideas over time.
So if you fast forward five years from
now, the quality of your ideas between now
and then can go up and down over time.
With risk management, five years from now,
if you've learned risk management
processes and you've implemented
and you've become fairly experienced at
risk management, your variability is going
to be low.
So your risk management, you've learned
once and implemented and built some
experience.
And then at some point in the future, your
black box variability will be very low.
So in the process, the quality of your
ideas over time can always change.
It's the effort that you put in.
It's the knowledge and effort of
generating quality ideas.
Black box variability, your risk
management is a fixed number.
It can become fixed over time.
It's fairly straightforward to learn.
And once you've picked up and you've
learned it once and you've picked up some
experience,
once you've picked it up, your variability
can be low.
So what happens?
You have profit and loss at the end of
that.
So the profit and loss is obviously
variable.
If your quality of ideas is variable and
over time, your risk management processes
and your black box variability becomes
fixed,
then the reason why your P&L is variable
is because of the quality of your ideas.
Once you know how to operate the black
box, it's all about ideas, which means
it's all about ideas, period.
When you're starting out, you have to
learn both, of course.
But over time, ideas are far more
important because risk management is
mechanical.
It takes about three to six months to
learn the basics and to become competent.
But it does require real money practice
and experience.
You can only get real money, real money
practice with good ideas or you're going
to blow up.
So again, it's all about ideas.
Now, fundamental trade idea generation, as
we've mentioned, is both quantitative and
qualitative.
And it requires a lot of attention to
detail, lateral thinking, creativity and
conviction.
And it's much more difficult to learn the
fundamental trade idea generation
processes,
the quant and the qualitative processes.
And implementing this over your lifetime,
over your career, a long period of time,
and generate consistently a large amount
of high quality trade ideas.
It's much more difficult learning how to
do that and actually doing it than
learning the risk management processes
and implementing them and getting some
experience doing that.
And this is conveniently why retail
traders tend to not focus on fundamentals
and the quality of their ideas.
And retail traders are given shortcuts or
what they think are shortcuts to learning,
shortcuts and hacks to learning some basic
risk management processes because it seems
easy.
It's easy and straightforward to learn
some of those processes, even though those
processes are not very sophisticated
and we need to do a lot more work on that.
But it does demonstrate as to why retail
traders do everything upside down.
The fundamental trade idea generation
process requires work.
It requires a lot of effort and it
requires consistency in effort showing up
every week,
every month, every month and generating a
large amount of high quality trade ideas
over a very long period of time in order
to sustain a long, short portfolio.
Learning the professional trader risk
management processes, even though it's
more difficult and takes longer to learn
than what retail traders are taught at the
moment and are used to,
it is still fixed information and it's
fixed information that you learn once and
then you implement and get some experience
doing it
over a three to six month period, what
really matters is your ideas because over
time your black box variability is fixed.
The quality of your ideas is variable and
the outcome, the P&L of your portfolio is
variable and it's over time driven by the
quality of your ideas.
So this is important stuff to understand,
guys, as to why we put so much effort as
professional traders into the fundamental
trade idea generation processes,
because we know over time that the outcome
of our portfolios is going to be
determined in the vast majority by the
quality and abundance of our ideas.
So, of course, it's a lot of work, first
of all, to initially understand the
fundamental trade idea generation
processes.
And of course, it's work as well on a
continuous basis to ensure that you're
generating a large amount,
an abundance of an abundance of high
quality ideas on repeat all the time in
order to service a long, short portfolio.
But that's what you're here to learn.
You're here to learn the professional
trader processes and the fundamental trade
idea generation process.
Now, if you recall, our returns
optimization visual from the beginning of
the foundations of portfolio management
section of the PTM video series,
the optimization visual, the key parts of
it, we have our view on GDP that is
expressed either through the market sector
or stocks.
And if we have a view that GDP is going to
be positive, we're going to tend towards a
long bias in the portfolio and we have
choices.
We can either be along the market and get
the market return, we can be along sectors
that we believe are going to outperform in
a positive GDP environment.
And in this situation, it's more than
likely that we're going to be leaning
towards stocks in our portfolio that we
define as cyclicals that will outperform
both the sector and the market.
And in this situation, it's more than
likely that we're going to be leaning
towards stocks in our portfolio that we
define as cyclicals that will outperform
both the sector and the market.
And in a positive growth environment, so
we're probably going to be having more
long cyclical positions in our portfolio.
On the flip side, if we believe that GDP
is slowing down or there's going to be GDP
contraction, we have our choices, we can
be short the market, but as traders,
that's not really our job.
Our job is to make a meaningful amount of
money, whether the market goes up or down,
so we could be short the market, but we
choose not to because we want better
returns.
We have the potential to be short sectors,
but if we want to optimize, we want to be
short the worst stocks in a particular
sector that we believe is going to
underperform the sector and the market in
a GDP slowdown or dramatic slowdown or
even contraction.
And in this situation, we would be short,
more than likely more cyclicals as part of
the overall portfolio.
But regardless of the GDP environment that
we're in at any one moment in time, so
whether we are in a prediction of a GDP
growth environment or a prediction of a
GDP contraction environment, it doesn't
matter.
But we want to be short stocks that are
going to be short stocks that are going to
underperform both the sector and the
market regardless of what GDP is going to
be.
So pick a random moment in time, we want
to be long stocks that go up and short
stocks that go down, and the longs
outperform the sector and the market and
the shorts underperform the sector and the
market.
So we get pure optimization in our
portfolios.
That's the aim that we always want to be
having.
Everything in between is inefficient.
So everything in yellow that you see on
the screen is not optimizing.
So this is what we're trying to do all the
time as traders.
We're trying to optimize our returns in
any given market environment and any given
GDP environment by being long and short
stocks that are going to outperform.
So long and short stocks that are going to
underperform.
Now, let's say in the example of having a
long bias.
So let's say we're leaning towards a net
long bias in the portfolio and we're
deciding to be long cyclicals.
So overly long cyclicals in the portfolio.
Well, we just don't choose any type of
cyclicals.
We have to be long the right cyclicals.
So good cyclical stocks for that moment in
time.
And we can also, at the same time, be
short bad cyclical stocks.
And or we can be short bad defensive
stocks.
And even at the same time, we could
actually be long some good defensive
stocks.
The main point to take away here is that
there's no hard and fast rules and there
is no absolute definitive rule book.
There's simply best practices that we tend
to lean towards.
At the end of the day, as traders, we just
want to be long stocks that go up a lot
and short stocks that go down a lot.
And we want to keep our volatility under
control.
We want to have the right portfolio
volatility, a decent, acceptable level of
correlation and the right bias.
So assuming that we have our volatility,
our portfolio volatility, correlation and
bias in place.
This is all best achieved by first
identifying all of the companies with good
fundamentals when we're looking for
potential longs.
We have to identify the positive and
negative outliers in each sector and run
an inventory of potential ideas.
And overlaying this with more processes,
these potential ideas become actual trade
ideas and then positions later.
So where do we start when we want to begin
identifying positive and negative outliers
in a particular sector?
Well, we start with a very popular, well
known metric in the financial markets
called the price earnings ratio, the PE
ratio.
When we're engaging in the bottom up
process to identify potential trade ideas,
the first metric that we always go to is
the price earnings ratio.
When we're actually looking at a
particular stock.
So when we're analyzing a stock right now
at any moment in time versus other stocks
in its sector classification.
So the peers in its sector that it's
measured against the P ratio is a
statement of how the world currently
values the company relative to its peers.
And it can be worked out in two ways.
So it can be worked out by taking the
market capitalization of the company and
dividing that by net income by after tax
earnings, or it can be worked out by
taking the stock price and dividing by
earnings per share.
However, the way in which professional
traders view and understand a P ratio is
totally different to the way most people
view it and understand it or the way
they've been taught.
P ratio, it is one of the most
misunderstood metrics in financial
markets.
You'll be very, very surprised that even
on the professional side, a lot of
professional traders totally misunderstand
the meaning of a P ratio.
Pretty much all retail traders have no
idea what a PE measure really is.
Smart professional traders know exactly
what it means.
And the key to understanding a price
earnings ratio properly is how to
interpret it correctly.
The problem is always with the
interpretation.
So, amateur and retail traders and even
bad pro traders and value investors are
taught and they believe that a low PE
ratio means a stock is, open quotes,
cheap, close quotes, and a high PE means a
stock is, open quotes, expensive, close
quotes.
Now, good pro traders.
Now, good pro traders think of it very,
very differently.
Their interpretation of a price earnings
ratio is very different to the way amateur
retail traders, bad pro traders, and even
value investors have been taught or have
been led to believe what a PE
interpretation actually is.
Pro traders think about it very
differently.
So, let's think about this.
The way pro traders think of it, and the
easiest way for you to think of it, is to
think firstly, how much is the world
prepared to pay for a company's forward
earnings?
Think of it.
Think of it in those terms.
So, how much is the world prepared to pay
right now for a company's future earnings?
Now, if that's the case, the opposite must
also hold true.
How much is the world prepared to sell a
company's forward earnings for?
So, right now, how much is the world
prepared to sell at this moment a
company's future earnings for?
These two statements must hold true at any
one moment in time.
Why?
Because we have a live trading market
where a stock at any one moment in time
has both buyers and sellers.
So, at any one moment in time, the stock
has a price and the stock price is divided
by the future EPS expectation of the
company, of the market.
And the stock price is a representation of
both what the world is willing to pay for
a company's forward earnings and,
simultaneously, what the world is prepared
to sell a company's earnings for.
Now, it's important to get your head
around this concept and make it stick.
The most common measure of price earnings
ratio that is used in the professional
world is a forward-looking PE ratio.
So, a one-year forward PE.
What we're doing with that is we're taking
the market consensus, one-year forward EPS
number, and then we're dividing the
current stock price of today by that
number, by the one-year forward EPS.
And that gives us the forward PE, the
one-year forward PE.
So, for example, if we are sitting in a
moment in time, that's say March 2023, the
one-year forward earnings number would be
the consensus mean number from research
analysts for the year 2023.
In November 2023, in November 2021, as an
example, because we're so much later in
the year, and the year is nearly over, the
one-year forward earnings number that
would be used by professional traders
would be the consensus mean number from
analysts for the year 2022.
So, for the following year, as
professional traders, we do not care about
one-year lagging.
So, the trailing 12-month price earnings
ratio, which is so popularized in
financial markets, we are traders and
we're trading on expectations of the
future.
We look forwards.
So, it's very important to understand this
major concept, guys.
Pro traders view the world and view the
price earnings ratio in a very, very
different way to the way retail traders
view it and even bad pro traders and even
value investors and investors.
So, let's get our head around this
further.
We mentioned, if you think about the way a
PE ratio is calculated, it's the live
stock price of a particular stock divided
by one-year forward-looking consensus mean
earnings.
And stocks trade every day, Monday to
Friday, and analyst EPS estimates
obviously move much less frequently than
the stocks obviously do because they're
trading every day.
Analyst EPS estimates tend to move in
clusters when expectations change.
Stock prices move based on the future
expectations of earnings of the market.
Now, PE is both an absolute and a relative
measure.
If you look at the table on the left-hand
side of the screen, what we've got here is
the oil and gas extraction sector.
And we've got market capitalization and
we've got the forward-looking PE.
And we've filtered in the spreadsheet for
the first year.
So, one-year forward-looking price
earnings ratio.
Now, we've not put on the screen at this
stage the EPS estimates themselves
because, at the moment, this is an
academic exercise so you can understand
this concept of PE interpretation in
isolation.
Now, if you look at the column with
one-year forward-looking PE, so this is
column L, we've highlighted two areas.
We've highlighted oil and gas extraction
stocks that have high PE's and we have oil
and gas extraction stocks highlighted with
low PE's.
So, have a look at those areas on the
screen.
What do you think of the stocks with PE
ratios below 10?
Do you think these stocks are cheap?
What do you think of the stocks with PE
ratios of above 40?
Do you think these stocks are expensive?
Have a think about that for a moment.
Meanwhile, just for the record, stocks
that you have in the table there that have
expected negative EPS, of course, if we
divide a positive stock price and divide
that by a negative EPS, so negative
earnings per share means a company is
losing money, they're going to have a
negative PE ratio.
So, here we're just looking at positive PE
ratios.
And we're looking at oil and gas
extraction stocks with very high PE's, so
PE's over 40, and then oil and gas
extraction stocks with low PE's that are
still positive, but low PE's that are
under 10 times earnings.
So, have you made a decision?
What do you think of the stocks with PE
ratios below 10 and what do you think of
the stocks with PE ratios above 40?
Are the ones below 10 cheap and are the
ones above 40 expensive?
Well, from a pro trader perspective, I can
tell you right now, two of the biggest
curse words you will ever make as a
professional trader is to say a stock is
either cheap or expensive.
So, let's go through a theoretical example
so you can remember this concept for the
rest of your life.
And the great news about this is that you
only have to learn it once and then it's
done.
All you have to do then is apply this
concept in your initial quantitative
processing phase when seeking out
potential trade ideas.
So, let's run through this example.
And this is a theoretical example of a
stock that is going down.
So, imagine we're sitting in the time of
the year, January, and we're looking at a
stock that has a price of $10 per share
and one year forward earnings estimate of
$1 per share.
What is the PE ratio?
Well, it's just 10 divided by one.
So, we have a PE of 10.
Now, let's say we fast forward to
February.
So, we're in February the same year, just
one month later, the company announces
that they're not going to hit the market
forecast.
They're not going to hit the $1 per share
in their earnings for the year.
And they're citing some problems in the
supply chain that they're working on
fixing.
And now, their own forecast, the company
forecast, they guide the market to $0.90
per share for their forward earnings for
the year.
Question.
Where does the stock have to go in order
to maintain its 10 times PE ratio?
Where does it have to go?
Yes, you've probably guessed right.
The stock to maintain its 10 times PE
ratio is just $0.90 multiplied by 10.
So, it has to go to $9.
So, a full dollar comes off the share
price.
Now, fast forward a month later.
Let's see what happens a month later in
March when the company announces that
they're no longer going to hit $0.90 a
share for the year in their earnings.
And they're citing a material change in
business conditions.
And they come out and they say, our new
forecast is $0.65 a share for the year.
Where does the stock have to go to in
order to maintain its 10 times PE ratio?
Yes, you've guessed it.
It's just $0.65 multiplied by 10.
So, now the stock is $6.50.
So, we're down $3.50 from $10.
Now, fast forward again.
Let's go forward a few more months to May.
The company announces that they're not
going to hit $0.65 a share for the year in
their earnings.
And now, they're citing a loss of three
key customer contracts.
And their new forecast for the year is
$0.01 per share for this year's earnings.
Question.
Where does the stock have to go to in
order to maintain its 10 times PE ratio?
Yes, it's just $0.01 multiplied by 10.
The stock is now trading at $0.10.
So, earnings per share, which started off
at $1, is down $0.99 to $0.01.
So, 99%.
And the stock price itself is down from
$10 to $0.10.
So, that's down 99%.
So, the point here is very simple.
On the journey that the stock took from
$10 to $0.01 from January till May, it was
on 10 times earnings, 10 times PE ratio,
all the way down.
So, at $10, when the stock was at $10, it
was on 10 times expected future earnings
for the year.
When the stock was at $9, it was on 10
times earnings, because there was $0.90
forecast for the year.
When the stock was at $6.50, it was on 10
times earnings, because $0.65 was forecast
for the year.
And when it was at $0.10, it was on 10
times earnings, because there was $0.01
forecast for the year.
How can we put this more simply?
A stock can be on 10 times earnings, or
the same PE ratio, and keep going down
forever.
Imagine somebody came along to you when
the stock was at $10, and told you that
this stock was cheap, because relative to
other stocks in the sector, the PE ratio
was low.
So, perhaps we had other stocks in the
sector at the time that were on 40 times
PE ratio.
And you listened to them, and you started
believing that the stock at $10 was cheap,
because it's on 10 times earnings, and
it's cheap relative to other stocks in the
sector, and you bought it.
Well, five months later, you would have
been down 99%.
So, a stock can stay cheap forever, and it
can keep going down, and be on the same
multiple all the way down, because their
earnings are going down.
Now, let's have a look at an example where
a stock price goes up.
So, imagine we're sitting in January,
stock has a price of $10 a share, one year
forward earnings estimate, $1 a share.
So, the same situation as before, except
this time, we're looking at an example
where a stock can go up.
And we're looking at PE in this context.
So, let's say in February, that the
company comes out, and they announce that
they're going to beat $1 per share in
their earnings for the year.
And they're citing supply chain
improvements that are increasing
efficiency.
So, now they forecast $1.20 a share for
the year.
Where does the stock have to go in order
to maintain its PE of 10?
Where does it have to go to?
Yes.
Yes, it goes to $12.
Now, in March, the company announces that
they're going to beat $1.20 a share,
citing material changes in business
conditions in the last six weeks.
And now, they're upping their forecast,
their EPS forecast for the year to $2 a
share.
Where does the stock have to go to, to
maintain the PE ratio of 10?
Where does it have to go to?
Yes, it goes to $20.
Now, what happens in May if the company
announces that they're going to beat the
previous $2 per share forecast for the
year in their earnings?
And they're citing a surprise upturn in
the last six weeks in their peripheral
European operations.
And they're now forecasting $4 for EPS for
the year.
So, where does the stock have to go to, to
maintain its 10 times PE ratio?
Where?
Where does it have to go to?
Yes, it goes to $40.
So, imagine back in January, in this
example, when a stock is going up, that
one of your friends told you in January,
when the stock was at $10, that this stock
was expensive, and you should probably go
short the stock.
The stock was expensive relative to other
stocks in the sector.
So, let's say this was a company that had
a high PE relative to other stocks in the
sector.
So, let's say as a 10 PE, that was the
highest PE in the sector, and the rest of
the sector had PE's of five and six.
And your friend tells you that this stock
on a 10 times PE is expensive.
And you shorted the stock.
You listened to your friend.
What would have happened?
Well, you'd be down $30 per share by May.
So, from the long side, when you're
looking at, for example, buying cheap
stocks, and they keep going down forever,
you can lose 100%.
Shorting expensive stocks can be even more
dangerous because theoretically, if EPS is
going up, the stock can keep going up and
maintain its same PE ratio.
At $10, the stock was on 10 times
earnings.
At $12, the stock was on 10 times
At $20, the stock was on 10 times
earnings.
And at $40, the stock is on 10 times
And your friend, at $40 per share, will
still be telling you that the stock is
expensive.
So, the point here is very, very simple,
guys.
Always, always, always remember, for
stocks that are going down, a stock can go
from any price to its lowest price
possible and still maintain the same PE
ratio.
And by the way, guys, this is not just
limited to the stock market.
This happens everywhere.
This happens in real life.
Let's go through an example as an analogy
of how this occurs everywhere, how this
occurs in real life.
Let's go through this analogy of buying
your wife or girlfriend lingerie for
Valentine's Day.
So, I want you to imagine that it's 6pm on
Valentine's Day and you're leaving the
office or you're leaving your place of
work
You haven't gotten your wife or girlfriend
a Valentine's gift yet.
So, you're about to leave your workplace
and you're planning to go to a department
store on the way home to buy some
lingerie.
And when you actually get to the store and
all of the lingerie, when you get there,
you find out it's sold out.
So, the whole area of lingerie in the
department store is empty, except for
three items.
And you're in a bit of a difficult
situation here because you have to buy one
of them.
Your wife or girlfriend is literally
expecting you home in 30 minutes time for
dinner.
And there's no way you can return home
without a Valentine's gift.
So, there's three items on the hangers in
the lingerie section of the department
store.
And you've got to buy one.
And you're going to have to leave very
quickly.
You're going to have to get home very
quickly with a gift.
Otherwise, there's going to be trouble.
Which one do you choose?
Lingerie A is priced at $50.
Lingerie B is priced at $150.
Lingerie C is priced at $500.
You have to make a decision right now
which one to buy.
Which one do you actually buy?
Think about it.
Now, warning, don't fast forward the video
until you've made a decision.
And remember, if you fail to make a
decision.
So, if you don't make a decision, then it
just means you're going home without a
Valentine's gift for your wife or
girlfriend.
You're going to be in trouble.
So, also, by the way, for female viewers
of the PTM video series, if you're
watching this, please just imagine
yourself on the other side, waiting at
home, waiting for your husband or
boyfriend to come home with your
Valentine's gift.
Imagine yourself as the receiver of the
gift.
What would you want your husband or
boyfriend to bring back with him?
Think about this, guys.
Think about this for a few moments.
I'll give you another 10 seconds.
Lingerie A, $50.
Lingerie B, $150.
Lingerie C, $500.
What have you chosen?
Well, if you went for lingerie A, you have
gone for what you perceive to be the cheap
option.
And, of course, we always have cheap and
expensive in our quotations.
If you've gone for lingerie C, you've gone
for what you perceive to be the expensive
option.
And if you've gone for lingerie B, you've
gone for what you perceive to be the
middle of the road, average priced or
sensible option.
The key here is, guys, is that price in
everything is a signal of quality, no
matter what we buy.
There is a reason why or multiple reasons
why something is priced where it is
priced.
What if I told you that lingerie A is 70%
polyester, 30% cotton, and is the least
desired brand on the market?
What if I told you that the best you can
hope for is that you will get three uses
out of lingerie A, and that's the best
case scenario?
What if I told you that your wife or
girlfriend will probably not even want to
wear it anyway, because it's cheap crap
and it's undesirable.
And in 30 minutes time, when you get home,
she's literally going to slap you around
the face and start crying when you present
it to her as her special Valentine's gift.
You're going to see and perceive lingerie
A completely differently than when you
just made a decision based on price,
because there's a reason why it's $50.
Additionally, what if I told you that the
expensive lingerie C at $500 is 100% pure
silk and is the most desirable brand on
the market?
What if I also told you that you will
easily get 50 uses out of lingerie C?
And also the intangible benefits.
What if I told you that when you get home
and you gift lingerie C to your wife or
girlfriend, she's going to be so
overwhelmed and excited that she's going
to get changed straight into it.
And she's going to wear it with a pair of
high heels while cooking you Valentine's
dinner, give you the night of your life
and you will be to her the best husband or
boyfriend in the world.
Well, for at least the next three months.
Of course, option A no longer seems cheap.
It is now very expensive.
And option C is no longer expensive.
It's now very cheap.
Now, just as a side note, because we are
doing this from the male perspective.
If you're a female watching this and you
were doing it from the perspective of
being at home and waiting for your husband
or boyfriend to come home with the
lingerie.
If you chose lingerie C, no problems
there.
You have high standards.
If you chose lingerie A, I think you need
to be asking yourself some serious
questions in life and probably knocking
your current husband or boyfriend into
shape and maybe think about raising your
standards.
So, jokes aside guys, price is a signal of
quality, okay?
And it's no different in the stock market
with PE ratio.
It's no different.
The multiple that the market pays for a
stock is a signal of the quality of the
earnings, of the quality of the stock.
You will be going into the live stock
market where prices are live every day.
And people, some very smart people in the
world are paying for, open quotes,
expensive stocks at a premium.
And they are selling cheap stocks at a
discount.
And you are going into the market, to the
live market every day.
And if you decide that your strategy is to
buy cheap stocks and sell expensive
stocks, your career is probably going to
be very short lived.
At some point, you will blow up.
At this stage in the quantitative process,
when you're analyzing relative PE ratios,
you always make the following assumptions.
There's nothing you know that the market
doesn't already know.
The market can stay irrational longer than
you can stay solvent.
So, think of the $10 stock example from
earlier, when the stock was going up from
$10 to $12 to $20 to $40.
And it was always on 10 times earnings.
When we walked into the market, your
friend was telling you that the stock was
expensive at $10 because other stocks in
the sector had a PE ratio of 5 and 6.
So, it traded on a big premium to the
sector.
Therefore, it must be, open quotes,
expensive, close quotes.
But guess what?
Every day in the market, somebody was
buying that stock at $10.
And of course, people were selling it as
well.
Otherwise, the people buying it couldn't
buy stock.
There's liquidity and there's buyers at
$10 and sellers at $10.
But the point is, the price is a rating.
And the rating, the PE ratio, is a signal
of the quality of the company.
And buyers are prepared to pay a premium.
That $10 stock at that moment in time, in
January, at the beginning of the year, is
like the $500 lingerie.
And your friend tells you, you should go
and short it.
So, you go into the market and you short
it.
Well, guess what happens?
Stock goes to $12.
Stock goes to $20.
Stock goes to $40.
And it's always, open quotes, expensive,
close quotes.
And he's still telling you it's expensive
when it's $40.
So, when you walked into the market at $10
and you and your friend decided
that this stock must be a short because
it's trading on 10 times earnings.
Do you think the market doesn't know that
the stock is trading on a premium to the
sector?
Of course they do.
There's nothing you know that the market
doesn't already know.
They know it's on 10 times earnings and
they are prepared to pay for it.
They're not stupid.
The market is full of very smart people
and there's nothing you know that the
market doesn't already know.
So, understand that.
Secondly, the market can stay irrational
longer than you can stay solvent.
So, you can see a stock trading on a big
premium to the rest of the sector.
Everyone knows the premium.
Everyone in the market knows the multiple.
Okay?
And you go in and you fight the market.
You say, I think the market is wrong.
Everyone in the market is incorrect.
Me, little Jimmy sitting at home in my
home office in my mum's basement knows
more than the market.
I know this stock is expensive, so I'm
going to short it.
Well, guess what?
Even if it's irrational, even if you think
it's irrational, the market can stay
irrational longer than you can stay
solvent.
The stock can keep going up on the same
multiple and it can be totally justified
why it keeps going up.
And you just lose all your money because
you argued with the market.
And this happens to retail traders all the
time.
We see it all the time when retail traders
come to ITPM and tell us that they've lost
money elsewhere.
And they were essentially trying to take
on the market by shorting so-called
expensive stocks or even buying so-called
cheap stocks and using a lot of leverage
to do so.
And they just get completely run over.
To be fair, it's mostly not their fault.
They've just been taught totally
incorrectly about what PE ratio actually
is and how to understand stock valuation.
But don't worry, you're here to learn this
stuff.
And like I said earlier, when you learn
this once and you understand it properly,
you only have to learn it once and process
it and make it stick.
Make the concept stick, then you have to
put it into practice over and over again
and keep practicing valuing companies and
understanding relative valuations of
stocks and how to interpret them properly.
Now, we're going to go through a real
example here from the market.
We're going to be looking at Wingstop, a
stock called Wingstop, and everyone knows
McDonald's.
So what you're looking at on the screen
here is a snapshot of the food services
and drinking places subsector from
accommodation and food services.
So the main NAICS sector is the
accommodation and food services sector.
And the subsector name is food services
and drinking places.
And this screenshot is taken in the first
quarter of 2021.
And we're going through a process here of
identifying outliers.
So we look, first of all, for high PE
stocks and low PE stocks.
And we start to make an interpretation of
the landscape of this sector.
So something else we've included as well,
we've obviously included market cap as
well.
So you can see market cap there in the
columns.
And we've got the first year, one year
forward price earnings ratio.
We've got two years forward PE ratio, and
we've got three years forward PE ratio.
But we haven't included EPS here for 2021.
We're just doing this for simplicity to
show the example of how it works first.
So for Wingstop, we can see Wingstop, the
ticker WING, is on 100 times 2021
earnings.
And McDonald's MCD is on 25 times 2021
And we can run a simple backtest of what
things looked like a year ago as an
example.
So in the previous year, in 2020, to see
what the multiples were and how the stock
prices performed.
So similar to our $10 example of stocks
that stay on the same multiple when they
go up
and stay on the same multiple when they go
down.
Obviously, it's a bit more messy in the
real world, but that's the concept.
And I want to show you a real example of
this so you understand it and the concept
actually sticks.
So let's run a little backtest.
Let's run a little role play.
There's a chart on the screen here of the
S&P 500 in 2020.
And we can see the lows put in on March
23rd, 2020 in the S&P 500 during the COVID
sell-off.
So imagine for a moment that you're
sitting at your desk on March 23rd, 2020.
The whole world is melting down.
The whole world's burning around you.
And we're at the COVID lows.
Obviously, you don't know that at the
time.
So everything's gone a little bit crazy,
but you're a well-trained trader and you
understand valuation.
And you're thinking, it's time to put some
money to work.
What do you go and buy?
Well, you obviously at the time on March
23rd at the COVID lows, because everything
was getting hammered.
You would have been faced with a multitude
of choices of stocks to buy across the
market.
But just imagine at the time you were
looking in the food services and drinking
places sector for stocks to buy.
What do you buy?
Well, you will have been presented with a
very similar table to the one that we took
a snapshot of in Q1 2021.
There will have been lots of high PE
stocks and low PE stocks.
And at the time, obviously, near the COVID
lows, going into them and out of them, EPS
estimates were being revised down
aggressively across the board.
And both Wingstop and McDonald's had
positive EPS estimates on March 23rd, 2020
at the S&P 500 lows.
So, if we look at the table below and we
look at the stock price, for example, of
Wing, on the 23rd of March 2020, Wing's
stock price was $62.76.
On that day, research analysts in the
market had a consensus estimate for 2020
EPS for Wing of 83 cents earnings.
Forward looking, one year forward EPS
estimate for 2020, which would give Wing a
price earnings ratio on that day, the 23rd
of March of 75.61.
So, we take $62.76, the stock price on the
day, and divide that by 0.83, so the 83
cents, and we get a PE ratio of 75.61.
Now, if we look at McDonald's, the stock
price on the 23rd of March 2020, was
$137.10.
The EPS estimate, the consensus forward
looking estimate for EPS for 2020 for
McDonald's from research analysts, was
$8.20 on the 23rd of March.
Which, on the 23rd of March, would mean
that McDonald's had a PE ratio of 16.72.
Now, we've added another column in there,
which is the stock prices of the two
stocks, Wing and McDonald's, on the 15th
of June.
Wing on the 15th of June was $120.14, and
McDonald's was $189.49.
That's what their stock prices were on
that day, on the 15th of June 2020.
And the reason we put those in there will
become apparent very soon.
Now, we've also calculated something at
the bottom of the screen there, which is
called the PE differential.
And we've taken that from our previous
table for Q1 2021, where Wing had a PE
ratio of 99.6, and McDonald's of 25.11.
And to work out the differential, we
simply divide the Wing PE ratio of 99.6 by
the McDonald's PE ratio of 25.11, which
gives us a factor of 3.96.
Now, that, if we multiply it by 100, gives
us a 396% premium that Wing is trading on
a PE premium versus McDonald's.
So, that is in Q1 2021.
Wing is trading in Q1 2021 on a 396%
differential PE premium to McDonald's.
So, as we go through this example, just
try to remember all of the data.
But just recall in the back of your mind,
the stock prices of Wing and McDonald's on
June 15, 2020.
And the PE differential of Wing versus
McDonald's, the 396% in Q1 2021.
Now, we can see our stock price and EPS
estimates from the market, the consensus
estimates, together for 2020 on a chart
here.
So, first of all, we're looking at Wing
stop.
So, we're looking at the whole of 2020
here, and also the first part of 2021.
And we're looking at the estimate periods
for the EPS estimate for annual estimates
of 2020.
So, the reason why it goes up to February
2021 is because that's when they reported
their 2020 final EPS number for the year.
So, at that moment, it can never change.
But what you can see on the screen here is
how on the red line, the EPS estimates
from research analysts changed over the
year 2020 versus the white line, which is
the stock price changing every day in the
year 2020.
So, we can have a look at our March COVID
lows.
And as we know, the Wing stock price on
March 23rd was $62.76.
So, we have our stock price on the
left-hand side of the chart.
So, the scale is on the left-hand side.
And on March 23rd, we also had our EPS
estimate coming in at $0.83 for the year
2020.
Our scale for EPS is on the right-hand
side of the chart.
And then you can see what happens to both
the stock price and EPS estimates.
What happens?
Well, the stock price in the last week of
March goes up and continues going up all
of April and then sideways from April to
June.
And the stock is around $120 by June 15th.
So, we know that from our table.
And the EPS estimates started to move up
in April and then went up a lot in May.
So, you can see the move in the red line
going up a lot in May.
And this was our EPS estimate moving up.
So, the consensus EPS estimates moving up.
And it moved up very aggressively.
And by June, the EPS estimate for Wing was
$1.04.
And by June 15th, we know the stock price
from our table for Wing was $120.14.
And the EPS estimate, which we're now
adding into our analysis, was $1.04.
And what about if we look at McDonald's?
We can do exactly the same analysis as we
just did with Wing.
We can look at the stock price and EPS on
the same chart for 2020.
And we have our scale for the stock price
on the left-hand side of the chart.
And our stock price is in white.
And we have our EPS estimate, our research
analyst consensus estimate, which is
always changing.
We have that in red.
And our scale for the 2020 EPS estimate is
on the right-hand side of the chart.
And we can do the same analysis as we did
with Wing.
We can look at the stock price and the EPS
estimate from the market at the Covid lows
on March 23rd.
And we can look at it three months later
on June 15th and just see what happened to
both of them.
So, first of all, we know on March 23rd,
McDonald's, the stock price was at
$137.10.
And we know that the EPS estimate was
$8.20.
Now, you can see the EPS estimate between
March 23rd and June 15th went down quite
significantly.
The EPS estimate for McDonald's on June
15th was actually $5.64.
And the stock price of McDonald's on June
15th was $189.49.
We know that from our table previously.
And we can see it here visually when we
look at the stock price chart in white on
the screen.
So, the stock went up for those three
months and the EPS estimates were down
over those three months.
So, it obviously gets a bit messier than
our theoretical example that we showed you
earlier with the $10 stock and $1 of
earnings in the theoretical down move and
the theoretical up move of a stock.
So, it gets a bit messier in the real
world, but we have made sense of these
numbers for you.
Don't worry, it's all coming up in a table
soon and will be fully explained.
But just try to make these numbers stick
in your mind for the moment and the
behavior of the wing stock price and EPS
estimates.
And the McDonald's stock price move and
EPS estimates over that period, March
23rd, 2020 to June 15th, 2020.
Now, what we've done here next is actually
looked at the performance of Wingstop.
Wingstop versus McDonnell's versus
McDonnell's over the period 23rd of March
2020 to 15th of June 2020.
And we've indexed the stocks to 100 from
March 23rd.
And we've looked at the percentage change
in each.
So, over that period, Wingstop was up
91.43% and McDonald's was up 38.21%.
So, obviously, in a very short space of
time, a big outperformance by Wing versus
McDonald's.
And when we tie all this together and run
this as a backtest, this is a very good
example of how PE works and the
interpretation of PE works in the real
world.
And what we've done on the screen here is
summarized all of this for you.
So, let's start with the stock price
outperformance of Wing versus McDonald's
over that period.
If we just look at the outperformance, so
the 91.42% performance in the period by
Wing minus the 38.21% performance by
McDonald's,
we get our 53.21% performance over
approximately a 60 trading day period.
So, obviously, our great performance there
in the time horizon that we like, the 20
to 60 day time horizon.
But where it gets interesting is actually
when we look at the PE ratios.
So, if you recall, from our original stats
taken on March 23rd, we were looking at a
75 PE for Wing and approximately a 17 PE
for McDonald's.
So, 75.61 and 16.72.
And the PE differential on that date was
4.52.
So, the Wing PE ratio is 4.52 times higher
than the McDonald's PE ratio.
So, it was trading on a 452% premium, Wing
versus McDonald's.
If we fast forward to June 15th, we look
at the EPS level of each stock and we work
out the PE on that date.
So, we had $1.04 for Wing and the stock
price was $120.14.
That gives us a PE of 115.
For McDonald's, we had $5.64 on June 15th
with a stock price of $189.49.
That gives us a PE ratio of 33.
So, the PE differential comes out on June
15th at a 358% premium for Wing.
Now, what's also interesting is that if we
fast forward an entire six to eight months
further ahead and we look at the PE
differential of Wing over McDonald's and
we look at that for Q1 2021,
when we look at the stats there, it comes
out at 396% premium, Wing versus
McDonald's.
So, if you recall, this is the data from
the big table that we showed right at the
beginning of this analysis of the entire
food services and drinking places sector.
The snapshot of the PE's in Q1 2021.
So, it's pretty interesting when you look
at the PE's and the differentials, the
premiums over these periods.
So, from March 23rd to June 15th, Wing,
the premium dropped, but it was still
trading on a huge premium.
And obviously, you saw the stock price
move.
The stock price went up, anticipating the
increase in EPS, which is very important
to understand.
The stock moved first and then the EPS
moved later and caught up with the stock
price.
And that was between March 23rd and June
15th.
So, we started out on March 23rd with a
452% premium.
By June 15th, it was on a 358% premium to
McDonald's.
And if you recall, the McDonald's stock
price went up, but the EPS estimates went
down by quite a lot over the same period.
And then if we fast forward six months,
eight months later, we end up in Q1 2021,
where the Wing PE is 99.6 and the
McDonald's PE is 25.11.
So, a 396% premium.
So, throughout this entire period, where
we've got Armageddon happening in the
markets during the COVID lows, Wings
premium was 452%.
Fast forward three months later to June
15th, it's still on a huge premium to
McDonald's.
And then we fast forward another six to
eight months later, and the differential
is around 400%.
So, the differential has been oscillating
between 358% and 450 plus percent.
So, really, it's kind of a gate between
350 and 450 over that entire period.
So, it's pretty interesting that from the
COVID lows during Armageddon to a total
reversal in the markets and entering a
bull market that the premium pretty much
stayed the same.
And on a relative basis, the market was
paying a premium in a bear market and in a
bull market.
But what it's really telling is the way
the market in Wing and McDonald's behaved
differently.
What it's really telling there is the
stock price movement in Wing before the
EPS estimates went up.
The market on COVID lows chose to buy
growth.
They chose to buy the quality in the
sector that's going to grow the fastest.
And yes, of course, the market also did
buy McDonald's, but they weren't buying
McDonald's for growth.
They were buying McDonald's for other
reasons, for safety.
Okay.
And this is why the Wing stock price went
up so much before the EPS estimates from
research analysts went up afterwards.
This is why the stock price went up so
much quickly because the market was
anticipating the EPS move.
And it's really obvious when you look at
it, why it happened and why Wing really
outperformed McDonald's during that period
and was still, the market was still paying
a massive premium consistently throughout
2020 and even into 2021.
And this happens time and time again in
financial markets.
It happens all the time.
And this is why the P.E. is a signal of
the quality of the earnings of the
company.
And in many cases, not just earnings
growth, but also revenue growth.
We're going to come on to this soon.
But for the moment, let's run through an
example of a typical portfolio situation
of what you could have done on that day on
March 23rd.
So if we think of the performance of Wing
and McDonald's in dollar terms, over that
period, March 23rd to June 15th, 2020,
Wing was up $57.38.
McDonald's was up $52.39.
So from an absolute return perspective,
they both went up between $52 and $57.
So it was a very similar absolute dollar
move.
However, when allocating risk limits in a
long short portfolio of, say, 10% of a
portfolio, so let's say on a $100,000
portfolio, you allocate $10,000 to a
trade.
A long short portfolio manager would have
had roughly twice as many shares of Wing
versus McDonald's, because the stock price
difference between Wing and McDonald's,
the factor is around two times.
So think about this in terms of allocating
$10,000 in a $100,000 portfolio.
If you bought Wing on March 23rd at $62.76
and you committed $10,000 in the
portfolio, you would have gotten
approximately 160 shares.
And that over the period from March 23rd
to June 15th, if you'd sold those at
$120.14, your upside, your profits would
have been $9,180.80.
The McDonald's shares allocation, if you'd
have committed $10,000 there with a stock
price of $137.10, you would have gotten
around 73 shares, 73 whole shares.
And that would have given you $52.39
upside on 73 shares.
So you would have had a profit of
$3,824.47.
So the outperformance there is on a
$10,000 position, $5,360 in outperformance
in dollar terms over the 60 days.
So that in a $100,000 portfolio is a 5.3%
difference, okay?
Which is obviously quite a big deal.
So imagine doing lots of trades over a
long period of time.
Having a 5.3% difference because you're
choosing the right stocks to be long is a
very, very big difference in performance
over many trades over a long period of
time.
And yes, of course, if you remember the
outperformance of the stock prices that we
calculated over the time was 53%.
So this translates linearly into a
$100,000 portfolio with a $10,000 position
into 5.3% outperformance, which is huge
over many, many trades over a long period
of time.
The difference between a portfolio that
picks the right stuff to be long and the
right stuff to be short is huge.
It can be a very, very big difference.
So being long and short, the right stuff
at the right time is very important as a
long, short trader and portfolio manager.
That's why we go to where money likes and
where money dislikes, okay, with our longs
and shorts.
And this is why the interpretation of PE
and getting that right all the time is so
important.
In the vast majority of cases in equity
markets, money chases revenue and earnings
growth.
And if you think about what wing is, it's
a chicken wing franchise business.
And it's in its revenue and earnings
growth phase with high percentage of their
product delivered to the door.
Okay, I think it's around 70% plus last
time I checked, but it's a chicken wing
franchise that's in its growth phase.
Okay.
And for the market at the time, what was
important?
Well, we had an economic lockdown with
COVID and all restaurants were closed and
food delivery was taking off, obviously
growing very quickly.
So we had a double whammy there with Wink.
Wink was a double whammy situation where
it was already in a normal market, growing
at a rapid pace.
And with COVID, it went into a turbo
overdrive.
McDonald's, as we all know, is well past
its growth phase.
It's a mature fast food business with a
real estate portfolio.
So the point is simple here, guys.
When you look at a table of comparable
PEs, you have to identify the outliers
that are both positive, low and negative
PE.
And always think to yourself the
following.
There must be a reason why this positive
outlier trades on a premium to the sector
average and a reason why this negative
outlier trades on a discount to the
sector.
So PE is your starting point.
It is your guide as to what the market is
willing to pay for and what they are
willing to sell on a relative basis.
Now, bear in mind, we haven't even looked
at the reasons why Wink was trading on
such a big premium to the sector average
and versus McDonald's itself.
However, it should be fairly obvious.
We chose a very simple example to
understand here.
Wink at the time, even though it was in a
defensive sector, is a growth stock in a
defensive sector.
And McDonald's is an ex-growth stock in
the same sector.
Wink had a business model that saw their
EPS not get hit at all by COVID-19.
Okay.
What was it?
Aggressive franchise growth and the
delivery model.
So very, very simple to understand.
But if you're sitting there and you're
looking at the sector for the first time,
interpretation of PE is critical.
The correct interpretation is critical.
So not looking at cheap stocks and
thinking they're a buy and looking at
expensive stocks and thinking they're a
sell.
But asking yourself the question and
making the statement, why is this stock or
the market willing to pay such a big
premium for this stock?
And why is the market willing to sell this
stock on such a big discount?
There must be a reason why the positive
outlier trades on a premium.
And there must be a reason why the
negative outlier trades on a discount.
What are those reasons?
And then you go off and you discover the
reasons.
Okay.
But PE is your starting point.
It's then up to you to do further
quantitative and qualitative work on the
stock to see if it actually is a potential
trade idea.
So we use PE as a guide, as a pointer as
to where to start looking.
It's the beginning point as to where to
start looking to initiate more work on a
trade idea.
Now, please note, we never said once here
that McDonald's was an outright short.
As traders, we would much rather be short
stocks that go down outright rather than
just under before.
The PE example here is to highlight where
money could be potentially allocated on
the long side.
On March 23rd, on the S&P 500 lows in
2020, even at that time, it was very hard
to find worthy short ideas.
But it was very easy to find a ton of long
ideas.
The point here is that at any moment in
time, you have to seek to be long and
short of right stuff.
If you were sitting there on March 23rd,
2020, and you thought that McDonald's,
going long McDonald's was a really good
trade idea,
allocating money to being long McDonald's
at that time was such a lazy, amateur,
retail trader, long investment idea.
It wasn't a trade.
Okay.
There's a big difference between a trade
and an investment.
It's our time horizon.
You would have been better off just buying
the S&P 500, which actually over that
period went up 38%.
So the March 23rd to the June 15th period.
It went up 38% over the same period.
So it was exactly the same performance as
McDonald's.
However, you should also always think
about the risk that you're taking for the
return that you're getting.
If you were to go long McDonald's, you
would have had market sector and single
stock risk.
But if you were simply just long the S&P
500, you will have had market risk of 500
stocks weighted by their market cap across
the 69 gigs industries.
So you will have had less risk.
So long the market versus long McDonald's
over the same period had better risk
adjusted returns.
So remember, this is why money was chasing
Wink.
They were happy to pay the premium on
March 23rd, which was 75 times earnings
because they knew that the EPS was going
to grow and the stock price was going to
go through the roof.
Remember, money likes growth.
And we can actually have a look here at
both Wink's and McDonald's past financial
reporting and look at their numbers at the
revenue and EPS lines from 2017 to 2020
and forecasts for 2021.
What you can see here is Wink's revenue
growth, which is pretty rapid.
So 133 growing to 153 growing to 199
growing to 248 million and then 282
million forecast in 2021.
And then we have EPS growth.
And EPS is obviously not as important to
this company because they are in the
growth phase.
So a lot of their revenue is being plowed
back into operations to expand the
business.
So revenue growth was more important to
this company even in 2020 and more
important for investors.
But investors are buying the company based
on their forward projection of EPS.
So they're buying for future EPS.
So yes, in 2017 and 2018, we don't have
EPS moving.
In 2019, it's down.
But there's a big change.
There's a basis change.
In 2020, we get big EPS growth.
And then we get some EPS growth in 2021.
For McDonald's, on the other hand, you can
see we are past the growth phase for
McDonald's.
A very typical situation here for a very
big fast food establishment, fast food
retailers.
And obviously, they have a big real estate
portfolio as well.
Their revenue, you can see, is pretty much
on a decline.
There's an uptick from 2020 forecast in
2021.
But it was on a decline for pretty much
four years.
And even in 2021, the forecast of 21.9
billion is not even as high as the 2017
reported number, which is 22.8 billion.
So this company, it's just not growing.
EPS, yes, there's a jump from 17 to 18.
But 18 to 19, it's slowing down a little.
And then 19 to 20, we know what happened
in 2020.
We go from $7.81 to $6.74.
And then from 2020 to 21, yes, we get an
improvement in the business for
McDonald's.
But overall, the picture is obviously not
as good as a growth stock in the same
sector as Wing.
So McDonald's past its growth phase, very
high market cap, struggling to grow at
all.
And then Wing, low market cap, a fairly
new kid on the block.
Not a big established company like
McDonald's, but they're in the defensive
sector, same as McDonald's, of food
establishments.
And they're growing rapidly.
So what happens?
Money likes growth.
So it trades on a premium, trades on a big
premium to McDonald's.
And the market is happy to pay for it
because they keep delivering on their
revenue and earnings growth.
Now, obviously, this is the first time
that we've shown you an example in the PTM
video series.
And I want to add some caution here
because we're going to be using quite a
lot of examples throughout the video
series.
So you're going to see a lot of examples
of stocks that we show you to highlight
points that ITBM is trying to get across
in order to educate you to a higher
standard.
And we don't want you to be a dummy here,
okay?
So do not, after completing the PTM video
series, start magically coming up with
trade ideas that include lots of stocks
from the video series.
Honestly, it's a very, very bad habit of
retail traders that when they see
examples, they start anchoring their trade
ideas to the examples that they've seen in
the past.
Do not do it.
Things change in financial markets and you
have to generate your own trade ideas
based on the principles and the template
of the PTM video series that we teach you.
We are using them as examples, guys.
So you understand how it works and you can
repeat it doing the same process in other
stocks over and over again on repeat.
You know, it's pretty amazing.
We've seen this at ITBM a lot since ITBM
launched, especially in our mentoring
programs where we get guys who have done
the PTM video series.
They then come on a mentoring program to
trade with live money in the markets and
they send us their first attempt at trade
ideas before the first phone call.
And we see trade ideas throughout their
first attempt at coming up with trade
ideas that were actually in the PTM video
series.
It's crazy.
It's like they're sending us the
information that we've given them back to
us.
So they're not doing any work.
They're not using it as a template.
They're not learning the processes and
generating their own ideas.
They're just anchoring themselves to some
trade ideas from stocks that they
witnessed in the past in a video series.
So it's pretty crazy, guys.
Like, don't look for shortcuts.
Don't look for hacks.
You actually have to do the work.
Okay.
You have to generate your own trade ideas.
And of course, we're going to go through
the whole process.
But always remember the four ITBM
principles, self-sustainability, work
ethic, free information, working smart,
not hard.
Additionally, guys, do not fall into the
hindsight trap as we're going through the
PTM video series.
What do we mean by that?
Well, pull up these examples at some
random point in the future and try to
figure out if they were winners or losers.
These are merely examples, guys.
Plus, at any one moment in time, they are
just potential ideas.
Remember, when you're going through
certain parts of the trade idea generation
process, they are not yet full ideas.
Okay.
At every stage, you have to do more work.
So they are potential ideas.
They may not have become actionable
positions later on in the process.
We are using them as examples at each
stage of the process.
And that is to educate you so you know
what you're looking for at each stage.
It's not, we're not giving you the example
saying you should have bought or sold
these stocks.
Okay.
So don't fall for the hindsight trap.
And even when we use these examples, if
they did end up becoming positions, we are
long short portfolio managers.
You saw earlier, we had a theoretical
$100,000 portfolio with a $10,000
position.
That can be quite typical of what retail
traders at ITPM would do.
You would have multiple positions in a
portfolio.
So even if one of these examples did end
up passing all the criteria to become an
actual position, we are long short
portfolio managers.
We have lots of positions.
And guess what?
Losers always exist.
It is a fact of trading.
And this is something that you're going to
realize later on in the video series.
So as we go through the examples
throughout the video series, guys, don't
be a dummy.
Don't fall for anchoring and copying trade
ideas.
You have to use it as a template to come
up with your own.
And also don't fall for hindsight trading.
So what's up next?
You pull up a sector, you identify the
positive and negative outliers.
What's up next?
What do you need to do next?
Does that mean all you have to do is
filter spreadsheets for high and low P
ratio and simply just turn them into
positions?
So go long high P stocks and short low P
stocks.
No, of course it doesn't.
That is your lazy retail trader brain
going to sleep temporarily and looking for
shortcuts and hacks.
You have to do further work to generate an
actual trade idea.
Remember, this is an identification
process.
We need to identify outliers using the
quantitative process.
And then we have to learn the stock info
and we have to identify KPIs, key
performance indicators and identify
catalysts.
So there's a lot of qualitative work that
goes into it.
So this is what qualifies as a trade idea.
Then we move on to timing and trade
structuring and preventative and reactive
risk management.
Also, and secondly, non participation is
always an option.
So if you see high PEs, but do further
work on stock and realize it's not a trade
idea because of other factors, then it can
be eliminated from the process as a
potential trade idea.
You do not have to participate just
because something has a high PE.
If you identify a high PE relative to its
peers and do further work on it, thinking
that because you don't know anything that
the market doesn't already know, therefore
the market must always be right.
And then you take a position in it.
You're not thinking straight.
We have a time horizon of 20 to 60 days.
It's highly likely that in our time
horizon, the valuation is probably
justified.
But that doesn't mean the stock is going
to go up within the 20 to 60 day time
horizon.
Also, it could be that the stock that you
go long in that time period.
So the 20 to 60 day time horizon, the
market could be wrong during that time
period and then afterwards be right for a
very long time, perhaps one year or even
longer.
Not arguing with the market does not mean
you automatically initiate a long or short
position.
So just because something is on a high PE
doesn't mean you initiate a long position.
Just because something is on a low PE
doesn't mean you initiate a short
position.
Yes, the market is giving you a signal.
Not arguing with that can also mean
non-participation.
You have to do further work to discover
whether the premium or whether the
discount is justified and whether you
agree with the market.
And then there's further work to be done
on timing and catalysts for a stock to
move within our desired time horizon.
So further work is required and
non-participation is always an option.
So let's summarize this, guys.
Some very important lessons here.
And it's been obviously a pretty long
video.
Let's summarize this, trade idea
generation.
It is without question the most important
ongoing responsibility of a consistently
profitable trader.
Without the oxygen that a constant stream
of high quality ideas provides.
At best, we're going to be a firefighting
trader.
However, we do still want to avoid being,
obviously, the useless pleb or the
reckless genius.
Ideally, we want to be long stocks that go
up and short stocks that go down and have
the right portfolio volatility,
correlation and bias.
So assuming that we have that in place,
this is best achieved by first identifying
all of the companies with good
fundamentals, potential longs, positive
outliers and all of the companies with bad
fundamentals.
Potential shorts, negative outliers.
We identify the positive and negative
outliers in each sector and we run an
inventory of potential ideas.
Then we look at relative forward looking
PE ratio as our first metric because it
signals quality.
And it tells us what money likes and
dislikes in the market.
So what are we doing here?
Essentially, we are allowing the market to
identify for us the quality and the trash.
That is our first step.
And that is our interpretation of the PE
ratio.
However, this does not mean that we are
done with our work to identify actual long
and short ideas that become real
positions.
It just simply means that we are
eliminating a lot of disinteresting stocks
that are likely to not become a
beneficiary or victim of extreme relative
money flows.
Okay.
So it's an identification process and at
the same time eliminating a lot of stuff
that as traders and PMs we are more than
likely not interested in.
So, guys, you now know the power of the PE
ratio and why it's used as our first
quantitative process in the identification
of sector outliers when we're doing our
bottom-up analysis.
The good news is you learn it and
understand it once.
However, you do have to apply it
continuously and correctly as an initial
process moving forward and forever.
Okay.
So, let's go back to the desk.
Let's summarize all of this and then we'll
move on to the next video where we're
going to continue to build out our trade
idea generation process.
Okay, guys.
So, welcome back to the desk.
We are now officially in the next part of
the PTM video series.
So, we are now in the bottom-up phase of
the trade idea generation process.
When we download data for the stock market
and stock sectors, we are going to end up
with a bunch of stocks that are all
defined as being in the same sector.
What we're seeking to do is go through a
series of steps to locate and identify
both positive and negative outliers in a
particular sector.
So, we're trying to find out what money
likes and what money dislikes.
We want the market on our side as traders.
That's very key to what we're doing here
as we're going through the overall trade
idea generation process.
So, where do we start?
Well, we always start with price earnings
ratio and we work backwards from that.
So, we start with PE and we work backwards
to discover if the market actually does
like or dislike particular stocks.
And then we look for the reasons why they
like or dislike a particular stock.
So, the first question we want to answer
is always what is trading on a premium and
what is trading on a discount.
And then we move on.
We work backwards and we work out the
reasons why something is on a premium or a
discount.
So, starting with price earnings ratio,
it's the quickest way to begin working out
what is actually going on in a particular
stock and what's going on across a
particular sector.
Then we look for the reasons why.
Okay.
So, now we obviously went through in that
video some theoretical examples.
And of course, it was quite entertaining
in terms of the analogy that we used.
But this is to get it so it is burned into
your mind.
So, you learn this and you never forget
it.
So, guys, always start with PE, interpret
it properly, and work backwards with the
right interpretation.
Let's head over to the next video and
continue with the trade idea generation
process and the bottom-up phase.